Wow seriously I just have to ask you how
are you pulling this off are you a
genius at guessing celeb noises then why
don't you give some of these underrated
characters a try
from the movies at Ariana Grande and
Bella Thorne starred in together to
Kristen Bell's cool cameo in Zootopia
this list is full of your favorite stars
and the movies they rocked
there's even an animated flick that
reunited three huge Nickelodeon stars
but can you guess who they are let's
dive in and find out oh my gosh this is
gonna be so much fun the actors who
voiced Jay in the Angry Birds movie 2 is
best known for being an amazing role
model and also for her time on Dance
Moms she's had a special on Nickelodeon
where we got to peek inside of her world
and she's recorded hit songs like
boomerang so what's your best guess it's
the iconic Jojo cui who didn't only
voice hatchling J in the hit movie but
also Keira the Eagle she spoke to just
Jared junior about her characters and
said that the trickiest part was
matching her voice over to the already
completed animation she also told them
that she hopes Jay eventually gets her
own spin-off and we'd love to see it at
Disney Channel star took on the role of
Ella in the same movie this actress is
an amazing singer best known for roles
in descendants and Liv and Maddie she's
also a phenomenal live performer she
brought her skills to hairspray live in
the role of amber Von Tussle
do you think you know who she is of
course it's dub Cameron Disney Channel
royalty who's definitely got the whole
package doves role as Ella isn't her
only voice acting credit she also voiced
a superhero she's the voice of gwen
stacy also known as spider-gwen in the
ultimate spider-man and marvel rising TV
shows stop to ask me if I was actually
guilty you definitely know the actor
chosen to voice Chuck another Angry
Birds character he starred in the
live-action Beauty and the Beast and he
was on Broadway in the Book of Mormon
but his best role probably the voice of
Olaf in Disney's frozen think you know
who it is
yep that's right it's Josh GAD he also
voiced Lewis in ice age continental
and demon on Bob's Burgers he was also
Wendell to bug in phineas and ferb Plus
Josh and Kristen Bell who voices on ax
in frozen just reunited in Central Park
a new animated show on Apple TV and of
course downward duck this Disney Channel
superstar brought his iconic voice to
Lou in ugly dolls you're probably used
to seeing him with his brothers on stage
and in movies like camp rock so who is
he it's Nick Donis our childhood crush
who can pretty much make our hearts melt
with one word so we're not upset at all
that he's been getting into voice acting
he and his brothers had another surprise
voice acting cameo when they were pretty
young but stick around because we'll
tell you more about that a little bit
later of course of course stay here this
singer co-starred with Nick as the
character Tuesday she's super new to
acting and voice acting so you probably
only heard of her from her many
successful songs including in the name
of love and I'm gonna show you crazy
think you know who she is
it's bebe Rexha who was also the writer
behind some hit singles like Eminem and
Rihanna 'he's the monster her role as
Tuesday led to her starring in her very
first movie but with a voice like that
we'd love to see bebe show off her
skills in another feature animation this
camp rock star won the role of Smurfette
in Smurfs The Lost village she's a
phenomenal singer whose recent single
anyone made huge waves at the 2019
Grammy Awards and she used to be really
good friends with Selena Gomez the two
of them even starred in a Disney Channel
original movie together any idea who she
could be its Demi Lovato the actress
turned singer who loved playing
Smurfette because they're both fierce
and resourceful Demi actually voiced
another animated character in the movie
charming she plays Lenore and was joined
by a fellow Disney Channel star
Ashley Tisdale who voiced Cinderella
we're Smurfs we do the right thing the
role of Smurf lily went to this Modern
Family star who has a talent for voice
acting
she's also appeared in ER and RL Stine's
the haunting hour and she just so
happens to have the same name as a
Disney Princess who do you think it is
it's Ariel winter who's super well known
as Alex Dunphy but she's no stranger to
voice acting she starred in tons of kids
TV shows though you probably know her
best as Gretchen in Phineas and Ferb and
penny in mr. Peabody and Sherman we have
to take you to smurfy Grove
snowflake the white gorilla is a fun
underrated movie that stars one of the
world's most famous singers as snowflake
she's known for her role in Nickelodeon
shows like Victoria's and she's also
known for saying Thank You net that's
right
it's ariana grande we thought you didn't
know that she starred alongside iCarly's
jennette mccurdy who voiced petunia and
nathan kress who voiced Elvis but this
isn't Ariana's first big animated
reunion with fellow childhood stars
Bella Thorne may be a Disney star but
she joined Ariana as the young version
of her character Laura in the underdogs
movie one of Saturday Night Live's
biggest cast members took on the role of
Lupe the eccentric goat in Ferdinand she
also does a really good impression of
Ellen DeGeneres hmm any guesses it's
Kate McKinnon playing Lupe was a dream
come true for Kate and she wants the
character to teach kids that seem true
to yourself is totally worth it and fun
fact
Kate's actually super good friends with
Ellen she even got a role in Ellen's
latest flick finding dory try some deep
relaxing breaths okay in this superstar
who voiced Queen Tara in epic can be
described as a queen in real life she's
an iconic singer and she starred in
movies like dream girls so who is she
it's the one and only Beyonce who you
shouldn't even be surprised as taking on
voice acting in addition to all of her
other amazing talents she was recently
the voice of Nala in the Lion King
live-action remake she also helped put
together the movies entire soundtrack
we're a performer that's so incredible
in front of an audience she sure seems
just as comfortable behind the scenes I
might have a hard time picking one do
you have a favorite
this next actress is a surprisingly good
singer which is why she got to voice ash
the rock star porcupine insane though
you probably know her better as an ethic
Avenger she
actually voiced a lot of animated
characters before like princess Mindy in
the spongebob squarepants movie think
you know who she could be its Scarlett
Johansson this black widow loved being
in a film about following your dreams
it's definitely a lighter role than some
of her other ones she was the voice of
the sinister snake ha in the live-action
Jungle Book which is a huge deal because
all the original movie characters were
meal and they came to Scarlett for the
role so that they could get more women
involved in the remake you do yes would
you like to see since Singh is pretty
big on girl power
they got another epic powerhouse won't
list a voice Mina you might remember her
from season 9 of American Idol she's
also won a Grammy for Best gospel album
for hiding place and she's appeared on
Sesame Street any guesses
it's the amazing Tori Kelly with the
voice of an angel it's no wonder she was
the perfect pick Romina
her favorite and also the most stressful
part of the whole process was putting
her own spin on hallelujah this was her
very first voice acting role but since
Tori loved the experience she'll
probably pop up in another animated
flick sometime soon
no I mean yes another powerhouse actress
took on the role of white mother and
secret singer Rosita this actress has
been Legally Blonde for most of her life
but we all knew she could pull off
synching thanks to her well-received
role in walk the line so what's your
best guess of course it's Reese
Witherspoon
she loved the opportunity to play a
mother who proves that she is so much
more than a housewife but seeing isn't
Reese's first shot at voice acting she
also voiced Susan Murphy in monsters vs.
aliens look I can't even keep counted
the steps my body parts aren't
responding okay she's a superstar singer
with her own makeup line but she was
also the voice of tip in the movie home
back in the day she was singing pone de
replay
you know her it's Rihanna the Fendi
Queen who also has some great voice
acting chops she co-starred in this
flick with the Big Bang Theory's Jim
Parsons who kept cracking her up behind
the scenes
the actors who voice tips mother Lucy is
also a successful singer she's known for
getting people on the floor and she gave
a wicked Super Bowl performance in 2019
we think you know who this superstar is
it's Jennifer Lopez another woman who
can really do it all
JLo is no stranger to starring in movies
but did you know that she was also the
voice of Shira in the Ice Age movies as
for her role in home she was chosen to
record the movies theme song feel the
light this world famous pop star used to
do a little acting back in the day when
she took on the role of Audrey in the
Lorax she's been in Valentine's Day and
was featured singing in Hannah Montana
the movie any idea who she could be its
singer-songwriter Taylor Swift she
co-starred with Zac Efron and the two
had a blast behind the scenes while she
was recently in cats she hasn't done a
lot of acting lately let us know in the
comments where you'd like to see taylor
next those are trees they used to grow
all around here we know this voice
actress really well she may have voiced
the tiny role of Priscilla the sloth in
Zootopia but she's had a whole bunch of
iconic roles and she's also one of our
favorite Disney Princesses from frozen
so who is she you're right it's totally
Kristen Bell she is absolutely addicted
to sloth so the small role of Priscilla
was a no brainer for her another
underrated role that you might not know
Kristen took on is Harper gym bow ski
one of Lisa's rich friends in the
Simpsons we thought you didn't know
about this friend star who voiced Sarah
Gardner in storks in the popular sitcom
she was known for her iconic hair and
fashion sense any idea who she could be
it's the one and only Jennifer Aniston
she admitted that the most
nerve-wracking part of taking the role
was having to hear her own voice in
surround sound don't be crazy you cannot
do the chimney the Brooklyn nine-nine
star who voiced Jonathan in Hotel
Transylvania 3 has done pretty much
everything he's been on Saturday Night
Live in a very lonely band and he's
starred in movies like hot rod and pop
star never stopped never stopping think
you know who he is
that's right it's
Samberg Andy has had tons of voiceover
roles and you probably didn't realize
that most of these were him he was Brent
McHale in Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs and jr. in stores
he was Brett in Bob's Burgers and Ricky
the Raptor in American Dad Santa Cruz
who knew that legendary sea monsters
could be such good fingers for the role
of the Kraken
so Hotel Transylvania crew needed a hip
young artist and it doesn't hurt that
he's pretty close friends with co-star
Selena Gomez oh and did we mention the
superstar is best known for rocking out
in a band with his brothers and that
he's also married to a start
if you guessed Joe Jonas then you got it
right this Jonas Brother was the perfect
choice for a crooning Kraken but you
might be surprised to find out that this
isn't Joe's first or most underrated
voice acting role he and his brothers
voiced the cherubs in Night at the
Museum battle of the Smithsonian where
they also got to show off their
signature singing voices in fact to get
things just right the brothers want to
chair a boot camp that sounds like a
once-in-a-lifetime experience does he
gets the groove going and everyone's got
a great time
which of these voice actors on our list
is your favorite let us know what other
animated movies you'd love to go behind
the scenes of in the comments section
down below don't forget to hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to the scenes for more thanks
for watching we'll see you next time